لقراءه اوسعافيه المشهد الميداني ينضم
الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه لواء فايز مرحبا بك
معنا اذا ما اردنا ان ننظر الى ما يقوم به
الطرفان الان في مناطق الاشتباك وعلى ماذا
يعتمدون وما هي اهدافهم في هذه المرحله
يعني هذه المرحله تقريبا منذ عده اسابيع
لا يوجد معارك حاسمه بالمعنى الدقيق
والحرفي والمهني من كلا الجانبين هي
اشتباكات
يحقق بعض احد الجانبين انجازات محدوده على
سبيل المثال اليد العليا في منطقه جنوب
باخموت هي للقوات الاوكرانيه وهي التي
تهاجم ولكن هناك تقارير تحدثت بمنتهى
الوضوح ان الخسائر كبيره جدا بحيث بمعدل
يفقد من اربعه الى خمسه جنود مقابل كل 100
متر يتم السيطره عليها
يقابل ذلك هناك اليد العليا في الشمال في
منطقه خاركيف وفي اطراف لوجانس واقصى
للجانب الروسي حيث يشن هجمات في الى الشرق
من ليمان ويح ان يرسل الى نهر اوسكال لعله
يجتاز النهر في عمليه خاصه تسمح له
بالوصول الى سنافيانسك واكراماتوريس اذا
ذهبنا جنوبا الى زبالوجيا
تقدمات محدوده جدا لصالح الجانب الاوكراني
لعلها تفضي الى الوصول الى
اذا البديل هو عمليات
القذف المدفعي القذف الصاروخي وبالتالي
دعيني اقول للجانب الاوكراني يحقق انجازات
تسمح بتطوير منطقه العمليات لشن الهجوم
الرئيسي الذي يتم الحديث ان هناك الجراند
ارمي لم يتم الزج به ولا الجانب الروسي
يستطيع ان يحقق انجازات تغير مسار المعركه
بمعنى اخر كان الجانبين دخلوا في
معارك استنزاف مضنيه معززه بالقصف
بالطائرات المسيره والقذف الصاروخي اذا ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك هل نحن امام مرحله شيء
يشبه الاستاتيكو
لا اقول استتيكو بالمطلق ولكن اقول بان
دوران في حلقه شبه مفرغه لا يوجد لدى اي
الجانبين حتى اللحظه التي يتحدث بها على
الاقل ما يوشي بان هناك انتصارا قادم
الهجوم الاوكراني
استنادا الى التصريحات الاوكرانيه
المسؤولين المرحله التمهيديه لكن حتى
المرحله التمهيديه جاءت دون التوقعات
الهجوم المضاد بمعنى المطلق والشامل والذي
تم الحديث عنه لاشهر وكان الجميع يحسب
حساب لحظه الحزم الفارقه لم نرى ذلك
الجانب الروسي
الى الدفاع عزز مواقع بخطوط دفاعيه عميقه
جدا متطوره جدا من الصعوبه احداث اختراقات
فيها فركنا الى الدفاع ولكنه يحاول ان يشن
عمليات تعرضيه في اقصى الشمال لجمله اسباب
اول هذه الاسباب الان تشويش وارباك
القياده الاوكرانيه من حيث توظيف الهجوم
المضاد للرئيسي اذا كان هناك نجاحات روسيه
هذا يعني لا اقول افشال او احباط الهجوم
المضاد للرئيسي ولكن على الاقل ابطاؤه
لانه يجب ان يوظف هذه القوات للتصدي
للتعرض الروسي اذا دعني اقول الاوراق
اختلطت اكثر من اللازم لا يوجد لا يوجد
رؤيه واضحه للمتابع والمحلل لانه لا يوجد
معارك حاسمه من كلا الجانبين تفضي الى
نتائج عملياتيه اللواء فايز الدويري شكرا
جزيلا لك